et on part tout de suite à londres où se
déroule le procès en appel pour
l'extradition aux états unis du lanceur
d'alert julian assange deuxième journée
elle sur place ses soutiens sont
toujours mobilisés vous le voyez hier
julian assange n'a pas pu assister à
cette audience trop affaibli
physiquement on retrouve là bas notre
envoyé spécial katia pique nique
katia bonjour on le voit derrière vous
les soutiens julian assange toujours
mobilisés
oui absolument intérieurement vous
pouvez peut-être entendre les prises de
parole il ya énormément de pancartes qui
a fait la libération du lanceur dallaire
et puis de nombreux ruban jaune
accrochée aux grilles avec les noms de
personnes qui n'ont pas pu se déplacer
je vous proposais d' écouter ses
soutiens
c'est pas du tout crédible c'est pas
possible on peut croire en rien à ce
qu'ils disent ni les américains en moi
on croit pas de dommage je crois pas du
tout à ce qu'ils disent et ils ne font
que dire des mensonges
voilà ne leur faisons pas confiance je
sais pas à qui on peut faire confiance
en fait l'importance du travail de
wikileaks
mais ce n'est pas important c'est vital
c'est juste pour un monde meilleur et
face à index d'assange est extradé pour
avoir diffusé des informations de
manière libre alors nous devons tous
faire face aux conséquences notre droit
à l'information notre liberté de parole
notre liberté d'accès aux informations
sur ce qui se passe partout dans le
monde et par des armées seront menacés à
cause de ça je
n'ai pas confiance car jusqu'à
maintenant le département de justice
manque de moralité d'après ce que je
peux voir tout le monde peut voir que ce
procès est une parodie faveur des
banques
les gens qui ne voient pas car les
médias ne couvre pas le procès ces gens
s'il savait la vérité s'il savait comme
ce pauvre homme a été malmené depuis
tout ce temps juste pour avoir dit la
vérité pour avoir fait son travail alors
il serait là aussi i'm telling de
cheveux de windsor
alors aujourd'hui à la défense du
lanceur dallaire contre l'argumentaire
du représentant des états-unis à la cour
qui s'est exprimé hier ce dernier james
lewis a contesté dans tous ses détails
le rapport psychiatrique était favorable
à julian assange genre de la première
demande d'extradition les américains ni
le risque suicidaire alors l'avocat
aujourd'hui de julian assange a assuré
que l'état mental du lanceur d' alerte
était structurellement propres à
déclencher des îles des envies
suicidaires et ce quelles que soient les
conditions de détention aux états unis
d'ailleurs sa famille ses enfants qui
seraient éloignés bien évidemment
aggraverait encore ce risque est de
toute façon il apparaît clair que malgré
les dires des américains il serait
probablement mis à l' isolement que les
garanties ne sont aujourd'hui confirmées
par personne des garanties qui ont été
données par l'avocat en expliquant qu'il
ne serait pas mis à l' isolement il
rappelle surtout la loi britannique
l'extradition d'un prisonnier à lanta
l'état mental dégradé est en soi
oppressif la loi protège ce type de
prisonniers qui ont des troubles
psychiatriques et c'est vraiment la clé
de la défense de julian assange
aujourd'hui l'avocat a aussi rappelé
quelque chose d'assez terrible hein que
la cia avait élaboré un plan pour
éliminer ou encore kidnappé de julian
assange et donc cela en dit long sur le
traitement qui pourrait lui être réservé
aux états unis voilà quelques éléments
de la plaidoirie de l'équipe de défense
en ce second jour d'apple merci à vous
quatre techniques pour tout fait
précision en direct de un drain